welcome to this video playing only to
logo on e to know who I think Stefan
tata is this urn and italian am
originally but he's got the spanish flag
yeah yeah a friend of mine recently i
mentioned that he is playing him often
hear per channel hehe and he said that
he's normally playing quite well but
this very slow so let's see what what
happens ok we get a same ish yeah i can
play with a form immediately let's see
at least whites intentions are not very
subtle you just hit you just don't get
everything everything rolling here in
the center ok yeah yeah i can cover with
Queenie to if I want yeah let's do that
yeah I've 25 now what to see exactly
what is she planning t6r when the
problem is I'm threatening now this d7d
526 with the strategical win so okay he
prevented that still still this is this
is dangerous I take six what exactly
look it looks dangerous okay I kick him
okay tries to get it back like that
I'm thinking about a really really crazy
move g-form yeah but I can't help it if
it takes you six with the night gtex f5s
is totally overwhelming and if he takes
on g4 I have 95 that that's very strong
I think covering these six attacking h7
if you place h6 up like weenie for and
like resins made on h7 and that's very
tricky for black maybe there is some
some hole in this with might be 3y are
some intermediate move but ok I still
couldn't resist a play that night b3m
maybe but after that there are they are
very very okay this I didn't even look
at okay I can take a five which looks
fairly strong doesn't it take care of
five
hmm gfive you have maybe maybe really
night be three but i have i have so many
i mean if he goes night be three
intending route be one takes on c1 rook
c1 and then take on a form i can i can
really i can even sacrifice the rook I
think 93 just every 5 9 a-1 really well
that that looks like a very slow move
but a key five just our luck g1 some
claim now you cannot take f4 anyway
because of a seven is to be honest I
don't understand that we should be seven
what's the point now this looks very
dangerous for blood in any case
yeah that's yeah I really am very
tempted to just to take only five I mean
even in Queenie five as a smooth but fe5
is what I'm talking about here mostly me
maybe Bishop f3
but just rupee one is just wrong yeah
but it's just strong yeah come on that's
that's really the simplest he cannot
take a force still because of a 7 and
you have this this he can do but it's
not it's not that great i think okay i
can take a form queen bee three in
quincy seven but this is not not really
working
ty morning yeah this is first maybe this
first check I can take with check but I
would double check now I had much better
ways to play I really had yeah I should
have should just sacrificed this bloody
rukon a one went win with a mate this
was probably probably just just possible
not sure what's going on here to be
honest I'm 124 seconds that's the the
big problem I probably check has a
working bloke ATM check
cannot you really think too deeply about
all this need to move check oh this is
the queen that was lucky yeah it's
according to what happened to earlier in
the game but black resigned but still
yeah I simply didn't convert it around
here widest of course completely winning
just a matter to play it precisely what
you won and here yeah maybe rupee one
isn't the best move from the way it is
given as the best buy the computer I
this was very tempting here this is this
line if he takes the rock Bishop g5 is
indeed winning and this also looks looks
totally overwhelming I mean something
like let's say it takes and then move
the Queen away this is just just insane
this is a tech yeah that's totally
winning plus 20 at the computer um I
came so what is the defense may be here
I wasn't sure about all this if you get
a check in may this is what persuaded me
not to give away the rook but the
computer even give chess is very good
for white q6h fine white is winning just
being a look down white is winning in
the attack here with Bishop b4 Bishop
ji-hye yeah I had the hunch that it is
winning and the computer is on stock
fishes on plus three so
it's a it's quite quite a lot ruki 8 is
then Bishop deform or age 5 it should be
for you yeah this is a very strong
attack I mean age 5 is coming something
like this check that's really funny yeah
it there must a master yeah there must
have been something okay this should
also be an advantage is right and now
King d1 yeah a computer gives me a
pretty substantial edge still but now I
am 49 seconds yeah it should shaky but
okay a win after all thanks for watching